[Music]
is Ben Affleck Dunkin Donuts newest
employee
not exactly should be a lot of fun on
Tuesday the Oscar winner was snapped
working the drive-through window in his
native Boston it was just a wonderful
rare experience that's been rocking a
Dunkin Donuts visor t-shirt and headset
surprising customers with free food and
coffee I've never seen anything like it
now I know what you're thinking
why well it's no secret Ben loves his
Dunkin Donuts in fact over the years
he's been photographed a lot and I mean
a lot with a dunking Cup in his hand
it's basically his signature accessory
you could say he runs on Duncan
like the slogan says
okay I'll see myself out it's great now
a source tells E.T Ben stint at the
drive-through is part of a much
anticipated commercial with the donut
giant quote Ben is heavily involved in
the commercial as he pitched the script
is directing and starring in it the
source adds that Ben's love Duncan for
years and has always been a big fan so
this partnership was natural quote Ben
is excited about it and has been very
into the campaign in commercial Ben is
really funny and charismatic he has been
making everyone laugh on set it's really
quite an experience and in a since
deleted video captured by a fan Ben's
wife Jennifer Lopez is on hand to
support her man joining her hubby behind
the counter as he thanks the crew and
jokes about his place on the employee
wall what can I tell you we're just
having a good time according to ET
Source Jen thinks the whole thing is
awesome and has been so supportive it's
a beautiful moment of course the two
tied the knot last year nearly two
decades after calling off their first
engagement in 2004. it was my first kind
of heartbreak we were about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just a bad heartbreak it was like
a tough one for me now Jen is set to
release her ninth studio album this is
me now the follow-up to 2002's this is
me then which famously featured a track
dedicated to her then fiance titled dear
Ben
love you
you're perfect
a manifestation of my dreams
the new album will include a song titled
dear Ben part 2 which will document the
second act of their love story something
she opened up to Vogue about back in
November the same way this is me then
captured a moment in time a very special
moment in time
this album
also did the same thing captured a very
special moment in time so this is me now
safe to say Ben and Jen now are booked
busy in love and fully caffeinated
[Music]